somewhere in this war ravaged gas
station Jeffrey Berry was told the dog
may be hiding
gingerly he and his team made their way
through the building until they spotted
the scared puppy that's what happens
okay
hitting around it Ukraine is one of the
most dangerous places in the world to
visit yet Barry and his team at the
non-profit no dogs Left Behind first
visited this summer to feed and
sterilize the pet population they
returned in early December at the behest
of the Ukrainian military because of the
problems of feral pet population can
bring we don't do that and we're going
to stop vaccinating sterilizing them
then they're going to have rampant
infectious disease spreading and we're
going to have rapid procreation and then
you got the next problems you know the
plan was to tour the blue zones areas
that had been occupied by the Russians
but were now back in Ukrainian control
sterilization campaign how do we
pronounce it
they brought six tons of dog and cat
food and a team to set up sterilization
centers in areas decimated by War
and as they soon learned under constant
threat of Russian bombardment we got hit
in in Carson Mrs landed
10 15 meters from us I mean our cars
went sideways okay and that's when we
had two military middle two military
personnel driving they turned us around
and said we got to leave now in another
location they found a makeshift pound
filled with dogs that had little hope of
surviving it's where Barry found a puppy
he named Yuki you got to do some work
and come back and get you okay and that
they did Yuki a dog of war ended up on
their Charter home to hopefully get
adopted from the Toronto Sanctuary out
of this crazy emotional
days
there's this one amazing moment
microlight Global News Toronto